la mobilisation a débuté dans l'après
midi et s'est poursuivi jusque tard dans
la nuit ce vendredi des centaines d'
aides soignants se sont rendus sur la
place bakou et d'ados à santiago pour
exiger les mêmes avantages que les
médecins et les infirmières une
manifestation organisée à l'appel de la
fédération chilienne des associations de
responsables de la santé car leur
profession n'est pas reconnue dans le
code de la santé du pays un moment donné
nous étions considérés comme des héros
maintenant comme des criminels comme
vous pouvez le voir il y avait des
policiers partout
en réalité au chili la démocratie
n'existe plus je considère que c'est
pratiquement une dictature qui est
exercée par monsieur pinière car nous
n'avons pas le droit à la liberté
d'expression
comme pour cette manifestation plusieurs
manifestants ont affronté les forces de
l'ordre qui ont répondu par des gaz
lacrymogènes et des canons à eau pour
disperser la foule
bilan de la journée seize personnes en
état d'arrestation
quelques jours auparavant le chef de
l'état s'était montré très menaçant à
l'égard de toute forme de violence
en démocratie nous ne pouvons tolérer
aucune forme de violence de quelque
nature que ce soit physique ou par le
biais des réseaux sociaux la violence
les menaces et l'intolérance sont
incompatibles avec une société
démocratique
selon les chiffres du ministère de la
santé la situation au chili continuent
de s'améliorer ce jeudi le pays comptait
le plus faible nombre de cases actif
depuis le 5 mai avec seulement 12 1289
patients positifs au co vite 19